incoming artillery fire could have been
rockets felt very close to the center oh
there's one
i don't know if you can hear that
[Music]
can you hear that mark
yeah very it feels very close to the
center of the city we are taking a
position
by the wall on the roof of our
hotel it's coming from a northerly
direction that is where we think
the bulk of the russian troops are
our alarms going off now i have to say
the streets are
basically
deserted a couple of days ago it was
like any other city now it's completely
deserted a couple of cars trying to
negotiate uh the snow
if if a reminder were necessary that
this city is in the process
of being encircled by russian troops
this serves as
an ex an excellent reminder of
of that it's still going on
thought it's like this drumbeat of war
reminding everybody
that the russians are close and moving
in i mean that is a very i'm just going
to stop speaking for a minute
could be rocket fire it's very very
quick
very intense
we're going to move in
very difficult to see because of the
snow
and actually the snow acts to muffle the
sound
this is a very intense bombardment let
you go john
i think we should let you go
and uh we're going to let john sparks go
here in kiev the sirens are going
we have seen troops running across the
square here
a lot of people
moving quite quickly
for cover certainly lots of troops they
had
just now we saw them with ammunition
boxes
and they appear to be
taking some sort of cover i think
it might be a sensible option for us at
some stage in the not too
distant future
in fact i don't know
whether i think i think we're going to
go back to neil patterson
in london and we will come back to you
uh once we get the all clear near uh
neil to you in london
mark thanks very much indeed of course i
think everyone will understand that the
need for our teams on the ground in and
around kiev and elsewhere to stay safe
so we hope they are getting themselves
into those circumstances right now